LAURENCE MORONEY:
Here, reporting
from the Coffee
With a Googler stage
on level two in the Moscone.
I'm going to be chatting
today with Ellie powers, who's
a Product Manager
on the Google Play
team, who gave us a wickedly
great keynote this morning.
Thanks, Ellie.
So tell us all about what you
do at Google Play and some
of the stuff you spoke
about in the keynote.
ELLIE POWERS: Well, so I'm
a product manager, which
means I work on all sorts
of new products and services
for our developers
and our users.
So we're constantly
trying to understand,
as the world of
Android grows, what
do developers and users need
to have a better experience.
And so for users that
can mean how do we
surface the right apps to them?
How do we help them
find what they want?
How do we help
them explore and do
the most with their phones and
tablets that they possibly can?
LAURENCE MORONEY:
As a parent myself
I saw some of this stuff on
families that you spoke about.
That looked really, really cool,
because my kids use the Play
Store all the time,
and I don't want them
to find anything inappropriate.
Could you tell us a little
bit more about that?
ELLIE POWERS: Sure,
so we saw basically
exactly what you've been
seeing with your kids;
we've seen that about a third
of Android users in the US
actually have kids under age 12.
So that's a lot of parents
who are out there trying
to find the right
content for their kids.
And so we said we can
do something that's
better than what we've
been doing before,
and what we're so
excited to have now is
an easy way for
parents to say, let
me find the right
content for my kids.
And the right content can mean
appropriate for their age,
but also aligned
around their interests.
So whether it's like
a favorite character,
if they're big fan of Mickey
Mouse or something like that--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Dora the Explorer.
ELLIE POWERS: Dora the
Explorer, that's my favorite.
They can go and find that
content easily and be sure
that that's going to be
appropriate for their kids.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So if
I'm a developer producing
child-friendly
content, how do I get
it like filtered and filed
and appropriately listed
in the Store?
ELLIE POWERS: So, if you're
a developer on Google Play,
you're already going into the
Google Play Developer Console
to publish your app
and check on the latest
stats, how much money you're
making, things like that.
And so if you just go in
there, click on the app
that you want to distribute
into our family section,
and then you go to a page
called Pricing and Distribution.
Down at the bottom, there's
actually a little check box,
and it just walks you
through the process.
It shows you exactly what
the requirements are,
and you can submit
your app, and we'll
let you know as soon
as it's approved.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
OK, so is there
some kind of smart work
going on in the background
to kind of pick characters out
of the app and validate age
appropriateness and
all that kind of thing?
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah,
absolutely, we
really want to have a very
professional experience
for the parents.
We want them to be
really confident in what
their finding, so we
do go in and make sure
that it adheres to all
the rules for the program
and make sure that
we're not filing
Dora the Explorer under "Star
Wars" or something like that.
So we'll make sure
that you can actually
find the right content.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I think a
"Dora the Explorer"/ "Star
Wars" crossover
would be awesome.
ELLIE POWERS: That
would be so awesome.
I guess we'd have to put it
in both places in that case.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yeah,
it'd be really, really neat.
Now I know you also
do a lot of stuff
with the Developer's Console.
Can you talk through a
little bit about that?
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah, absolutely,
so one of the biggest
challenges we're seeing the
developers are facing today
is that they want to just
bring more users to their apps.
So in addition to everything
we're doing on the user side
in terms of surfacing
the right apps to users,
we're also making it so that
developers can take action
to make their apps
more discoverable
and to make users more
likely to install it.
So there's a couple big
things we're doing there.
The first one is
we're making it really
easy for developers to
create advertising campaigns.
So if you haven't
tried it before,
we want to make it possible
with just a couple clicks
to start advertising.
So we have something new in
the developer console called
Universal App Campaigns,
and all you need to know
is just the total budget
that you want to spend
and the amount that you
want to pay per user.
And we just make it easy.
Within a couple minutes you, can
set up your whole ad campaign,
and we'll go and we'll
select the right inventory
across Google search, YouTube,
AdWords, and the Play Store
Search ads as well, and
so that's really easy.
And so probably the
next thing you probably
want to see after that
is, well, is it working?
If I'm doing certain types
of marketing activities,
which ones are going
well, which ones aren't?
Where do I want to double down?
Where do I want to cut back?
So we have a new page that we're
calling the Conversion Funnel,
and so you're able to
see all of basically user
traffic in the
Play Store, and you
can see how many users look
at your page on Play, how
many of them actually
installed the app,
and then how many went
on to spend money.
And you can also
break that down based
on how the user found your app.
So you can see, oh, this
ad campaign that I created,
this is how many installs
it was able to get me.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Sweet-- I also saw
that you have like an AB testing
kind of thing in the Play Store
itself, so you can
test your listings?
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah,
that's exactly right.
So a lot of developers
say that they
want to make the best
store listing that's going
to appeal to the most users.
But how are you supposed
to know if like a red icon
our a blue icon is going
to be most effective?
And you can get in the
conversation all day,
but without data,
it's not really clear
what you're supposed to do.
So you can just create up
to three different variants
of your store listing in the
Google Play Developer Console,
and then we go on and we test
those new graphics and texts
across a bunch of users.
And then we'll tell you, hey,
it looks like this one here
is the winner, and you can
just switch over to it.
You don't have to do any math.
You don't have to
write any code.
We just create
everything for you,
and all you need to provide
is the graphics and the text.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Nice, and
if I want to make changes
to my graphic and text based
on feedback from this testing,
it's pretty fast for me to
filter that into the store?
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah, absolutely,
you can just make the change.
We'll say, this
option is the winner,
and you can just click
on it, and say, yep,
I want to make that my
new Play Store listing.
And then very soon, it'll
show up there for everybody.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool,
and one other thing
that I saw that I was really
excited by was developers
can actually have their
own page in the store
where they list
all of their, apps
and I think that's
really powerful.
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah, we're
really excited about that, too.
Some developers have maybe
just one or two apps,
but other developers have a
very large catalog actually
of what they've created.
And a lot of developers have
told us, well, wouldn't it
be nicer if there was just a
single place in the Play Store
where they can send users.
They could say check
us out on Google Play
and send the users
to that one page.
So now we've made it so that
developers can customize
that page, and they can really
give it a flavor of their brand
by putting custom
graphics there.
And then if they
have a certain title,
maybe they've just
launched a new game,
they can feature that one
at the top of the list,
and then users can go and
explore the other apps
and games that they have, too.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And I personally
found it's a great
way to discover things
that I like, is
that usually, if I
like one app from
a developer, it's
like liking a book from
a particular author,
that you tend to like the
other ones from that author.
So if I have that page where
I can see the other apps
from that developer, it's
great for me as the user,
and it's great for
that developer, too.
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah,
absolutely, we really
hope this can be a way to build
loyal fans like you, where
you say, oh I like the first
game from this developer.
I'm going to try the
next one and the next one
and the next one after that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Exactly, and
like if I'm an app developer,
how do I go about getting one of
those pages or setting that up?
ELLIE POWERS: Well it's all in
the Developer Console, again,
so you just go there.
You click on your store listing,
and there's a new experiment
section, and you can set up
all the different experiments
that you want to run,
and you can go there.
And you can also go to find your
developer page in your profile
section, too.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool,
so basically the Console
is a one-stop shop
for all of this stuff?
ELLIE POWERS: Yeah, anything
you want to do on Google Play,
you can just go to the
Developer Console right there.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Cool, well thank you.
Is there anything else?
We've covered so much.
ELLIE POWERS: Gosh, I think
that's pretty much it.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
That's pretty awesome.
So a lot of great new
announcements today.
Thanks so much
for coming, Ellie.
This has been fabulous.
Great job with the
keynote this morning.
It was just wonderful.
We've looked at
so many new things
that are available in the
Google Play Developer Console.
As Ellie mentioned,
there's the advertising.
There's the AB testing.
There's a developer page.
There's the
family-friendly stuff,
and there's great new stuff
available for Play Games
developers.
So just go and check out the
Google Play Developer Console.
If you're submitting any apps,
if you're submitting any games,
there's lots of great new
tools on there for you.
So thanks, Elie.
ELLIE POWERS: Thank you.